en ukraine sur le front militaire les
troupes russes se regroupent sans doute
pour lancer une offensive sur le donbass
et puis côté diplomatie l'événement
l'image forte de cette journée c'était
le président ukrainien devant les
nations unies cet après midi quand un
chalmé
face à la communauté internationale
volodymyr zelensky a lancé un nouvel
appel à l'action invité du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu le président ukrainien
n'a pas mâché ses mots hier je me suis
rendu à abuja et je me suis rendu compte
que les forces militaires ont commis
d'innombrables crimes le monde voit
aujourd'hui ce que les russes ont fait à
bout de chats dans une ville sous
occupation mais le monde n'a pas encore
vu ce que les russes ont fait dans
d'autres villes et régions occupées de
notre pays mesdames et messieurs êtes
vous prêt à renoncer au droit
international au rôle des nations unies
si tel n'est pas le cas il faut agir
immédiatement un discours sur fond de
bras de fer avec la russie qui dénoncent
toujours une manipulation des images du
charnier de boudhha know if you look et
à polluer maintenant si vous regardez
attentivement ce que vous voyez à butch
à les cadavres qui gisent dans les rues
on ne peut échapper à la conclusion que
c'est une mise en scène que c'est faux
que c'est une provocation
une version démentie par des images
satellites de boudhha et analysées par
plusieurs médias dont le new york times
elle démontre que les corps présents
dans les rues de la ville étaient bien
déjà présent le 19 mars soit plus de 10
jours avant le départ des troupes russes
la commission européenne a réagi à ce
qu'elle a qualifié d' images
épouvantables à bout de chats oiseaux
la russie mène une guerre cruel et
impitoyable qu'elle dirige non seulement
contre les troupes courageuse de
l'ukraine mais aussi contre sa
population civile les quatre trains de
sanctions ont durement touchés et
limiter les options politiques et
économiques du kremlin nous élargirons
et renforceront ses sanctions afin
qu'elles affectent encore plus
profondément l'économie russe
la présidente de la commission propose
ainsi la fermeture des ports européens
au navire plus la fin des transactions
avec quatre banques ou encore
l'interdiction d'importation du charbon
russe ce soir le patron de l'otan a dit
se préparer à la découverte d'autres
atrocités commises en ukraine selon lui
la russie se renforce pour prendre le
contrôle de l'ensemble du dombass à
l'est du pays et on va analyser les
événements marquants de cette journée
avec le général dominique trinquant
bonsoir en juin l'ancien chef de la
mission militaire française auprès de
l'onu irin à dmitry chine bonsoir vous
êtes maître de conférences en langue et
civilisation ukrainienne à l'institut
national des langues et civilisations
orientales
johan kirk amont soir doctorante à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas
spécialiste en droit international et en
droit des conflits armés laetitia cru
pas et rester à mes côtés peut-être le
la stratégie de l'armée russe pour
commencer je commence donc avec vous
général trinquant qu'est ce qu'on peut
imaginer craindre dans les prochaines
heures on parle beaucoup d'une offensive
qui se préparerait à l'aise dans le
donbass et c'est ce qui semble plus
probable oui alors d'abord il faut
prendre un peu de recul sur les cinq
dernières semaines va en fait la
première phase c'était la saisie du
pouvoir à kiev rapide probablement un
montage du fsb qui n'a pas fonctionné
ça c'est la première phase donc le fsb
qui a dit vous inquiétez pas tout ça ça
va se passer rapidement français qui
pensait que le pouvoir les pénalités qui
pourraient placer un fantoche ensuite
l'armée russe s'est fait c'est ce
qu'elle fait faire l attaque sur quatre
axes kiev kharkiv donbass et le long de
la mer d'azov et puis au bout de trois
semaines ils voient qu'il ya trois axes
qui ne progresse pas et il y en a un qui
progresse stratégie russe on renforce le
succès on abandonne là où on n'a pas de
succès et donc tous les renforcements
vont vers la ligne entre le dombass et
la crimée qui a gagné une bonne partie
est là la clé c'est la chute de mario
pole parce qu'une fois que mario paul
est tombé le président poutine peut dire
victoire mario paul est tombé et s'il a
progressé un peu dans le combat ce
libération du donbass ce que je voudrais
rappeler que quand il était sur le stade
à moscou il ya quinze jours à peu près
il ne parlait que de la guerre du
lombard donc pour le peuple russe guerre
du donbass on a gagné le dombass alors
maintenant la concentration des efforts
sur cette ligne là est tout de même
difficile d'abord bien sûr à cause de la
résistance à mario pole mais aussi parce
que les rues sont pas pas beaucoup de
réserve actuellement ils ont fait appel
il ya 300 syriens qui sont arrivés
un millier de wagner qui arrivent de
libye on voit qu'on fait quand même du
bric de broc 1 il ya des forces qui
arrive de vladivostok donc vous vous
imaginez la traversée que ça représente
et celles qui arrivent de kiev du nord
ça fait 2000 km 1 pour revenir dans le
bon bah ce en faisant le tour alors que
les ukrainiens sont en position centrale
donc que pour basculer leur force c'est
quand même plus facile donc ma question
aujourd'hui c'est ils vont consolider le
sud mais que vont ils faire après
l'option s'ils ont vraiment des forces
mais j'y crois pas trop c'est d'arriver
à couper les forces ukrainienne qui sont
face aux dons parce qu'ils sont les
meilleurs forces qui sont enterrés
depuis huit ans qu'ils sont bien équipés
et donc en faisant la liaison entre
mario paul et la ville qui est dont j'ai
oublié le nom qui est juste au sud qui
ont pris non non non en dessous de
kharkiv il yuzu un nom comme ça et donc
pas les liaisons entre les deux hélas si
vous laissez la ligne maginot
ukrainienne donc si ils arrivent à
enfermer ses meilleures troupes ça c'est
important d'où la demande du président
hélène ce qui est aujourd'hui d'apporter
de l'armement lourd parce qu'il se
trouve face à des blindés de
l'artillerie il faut d'armement l'eau
ensuite il ya bien sûr odessa dont on
parle depuis longtemps mais ils ont été
arrêtés à nicolaï et donc par la terre
et ne peuvent plus prendre maintenant
odessa il ya un blocus maritime un don
qui les bloque et dont vous parliez des
notamment des soldats russes qui étaient
autour de kiev qui sont revenus
une amie three sides et
vers ce nouveau front mais que sait-on
du moral de ses soldats russes c'est ça
qui est intéressant à a évoqué aussi
bien d'abord on a dit qu'il allait être
retirés ensuite on se rend compte qu'ils
vont être apparemment réaffecter selon
les britanniques qui parle du d'abord du
moral très bas mais ce dont l'a constaté
sur place parce qu'on on recoupe
aujourd'hui l'information très
rapidement et je pense qu'il est les
autorités russes ne se rendait pas
compte que ça sera aussi aussi rapide on
sait qu'il ya quand même des exactions
qui est des viols il y avait des actes
de barbarie et il ya eu des pillages et
surtout donc ses troupes qui s'était
retiré en biélorussie on se rend compte
que la première chose qu'ils avaient
fait c'est d'aller à la poste et
d'envoyer dans le vers leurs familles
huit ans qui a été pris et aujourd'hui
on à grasse je ne sais pas s'ils sont
les les bureaux de poste qui ont qui ont
fait les fuites ou qui ou si c'était les
hackers mais on sait très bien qu'ils
étaient l'expéditeur qui est les
récipiendaires quel est le poids qui a
été envoyée on parle entre 81 kg de
vêtements aux 400 kg de d'instruments de
musique où est donc cette façon c'est
extrêmement précis et donc et donc ça ça
montre quand même que d'abord le pillage
a été institutionnalisée couvert et que
donc le moral de ses troupes est quand
même pas vraiment du côté du que vous
dites institutionnalisée ou alors il ya
une sorte de laisser faire comme environ
4,5 kg on ne peut pas le cacher dans sa
poche c'est à dire que c'est quelque
chose qui est qui a sans doute était jus
est autorisée plus ou moins donc c'est
ce que ce qu'on a vu on va revenir on
c'était le thème de notre débat
évidemment hier mais sur sur le ces
images ailleurs all iberian ce qui en a
diffusé
une partie devant l'onu cet après midi
ces images qu'on a tous des découvertes
de boudhha qu'est ce que ça dit de
l'armée russe quand même généré 5 ans
alors
d'abord la question
c'est est-ce que c'est uniquement dans
la région de boue de chat ou au nord-est
également parce que ça peut être le cas
d'une unité particulièrement mal
encadrée dans lesquels l'encadrement
l'espace et deux points sur l'armée
russe la violence fait partie de l'armée
russe les jeunes conscrits qui arrive au
service militaire sont brutalisés c'est
une tradition qui est connue qui a été
soulevé de nombreuses fois qu'ils
existent deuxième point l'armée russe
manque d'encadrement intermédiaire elle
a pas de sous-officiers et là des
officiers et des soldats est donc le
seul officier si vous voulez c'est celui
qui au plus près de la troupe et qui
fait respecter la discipline donc
globalement plus alors je rajoute un
troisième élément qui est la propagande
qu'ils reçoivent depuis de vin en russie
rien et qui fait que la force la
brutalité etc font partie des heureux
des noms qu'on a vu filmé les images ne
serait le fait que d'une unité de alors
c'est la question que je pose moi il ya
une brutalité est-ce que c'est dû à une
unité particulière et inédite et peut
faire ces dégâts une seule bannière ben
oui une unité âge quand par l'unité
c'est un régiment régiment se tient une
ville donc voilà c'est ça ou une brigade
mais peu importe c'est ces unités et qui
du coup aussi pillé après ça parce que
tout est permis si vous voulez on laisse
faire on laisse boire les soldats on
laisse comme ils ont bu bas amuse toi
avec les filles du coin tutu et ses
allées les snipers qui des ukrainiens
qui disaient ils s'amusaient à descendre
les gens parce qu'il devait s'ennuyer en
étant en ligne arrière donc on descend
les gens donc ma question c'est une
question je n'ai pas ma réponse et
brutalité dans l'armée russe normal et
puis ces dérapages parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'encadrement et parce que la propagande
les à un bib et depuis 20 ans voilà
maintenant est ce que c'est le fait
d'une unité ou de toutes les unités
russes jeune ancien lavoir que les
enquêtes avancent et dangereux tourne
vers vous gêne kirkham ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on l'a évoqué dans
le dans le sujet de quentin calme sl
c'est quand même la rapidité du temps
médiatique c'est hier que maintenant on
a très vite des images des images
satellites qui sont recoupées ça est ce
que ça peut accélérer aussi le temps
judiciaire parce qu'on sait que la
justice a besoin de sérénité de temps
pour avancer et prendre sa décision
alors effectivement la justice a besoin
de temps mais ce qui est assez
impressionnant effectivement dans le cas
de l'ukraine c'est que ça va aider pour
la partie de l'anc est c'est à dire que
tant que le conflit n'est pas terminé on
n'a pas avancé un certain nombre de
qualification juridique ne pourront pas
être avancée par exemple on a beaucoup
entendu le qualificatif de génocide
ça il va falloir attendre d'avoir accès
à des plans savoir s'il y avait une
intention d'état savoir si c'était
calculé qu'on voulait exterminer tout ou
partie de la population parce qu'ils
étaient et craignant que ça ne fera pas
avancer des qualifications par contre ça
permettra et c'est en ce sens que le
procureur de la cour pénale
internationale est intervenue ça
permettrait en tout cas de recouper
d'identifier et de potentiellement
poursuivre ensuite donc ses rangs une
masse d'informations qu'il faut traiter
avec des pincettes puisqu'il faudra les
identifier ensuite toutes les images des
réseaux sociaux ne sont pas fiables pour
l'instant et on a vu qu effectivement
pour ce qui est de boudhha bas il ya un
travail énorme des journalistes pour
l'identification des dates et des
personnes et ce travail là serait
effectivement très utile pour la justice
ensuite ça mais ça va prendre combien de
temps c'est en année que on calcule si
on parle de la cour pénale
internationale or il ya plein de
procédure en même temps mais si on parle
de la cour pénale internationale c'est
forcément en année que que le colon que
l'on calcule ou quoi oui ce sera
forcément en année est en fait la
compagnie l'international souffre aussi
d'un manque de moyens financiers pour
l'instant parce qu'elle est financée
directement par les états donc ce sont
eux en fait qu'ils vont devoir donner
l'argent à la cour pénale internationale
pour qu'elle puisse poursuivre ses
travaux savané 6 aidé énormément
d'experts sur le terrain on en a vu qui
ont commencé à se déplacer en ukraine y
ait des commission onusienne
et des copains des experts indépendants
des nations unies qui commence elle est
sur un terrain donc tout ça va prendre
du temps et met en parallèle et
effectivement on voit bien qu'il ya une
saisine de la communauté internationale
et qu'en tout cas même dans les
juridictions internes qui vont aussi
devoir faire un travail qui ne sera pas
fait en russie malheureusement où il
sera fait ailleurs donc on verra que la
justice avant sera en tout cas au niveau
international faudra attendre
effectivement je passe quelques
déceptions j'espère que jean piette pas
sur le reste mais j'entends dire que
vladimir poutine de toute façon ne
pourra pas être jugé par la cpi parce
que la russie ni la russie ni l'ukraine
ont signé le therese de ratification qui
consent à l'existence de cette cpi alors
quelques va-t-il arriver pour lui alors
pour vladimir poutine effectivement si
jamais à un moment la seule russie
ratifié la cpi on parle d'un cas
complètement hypothétique il pourrait
être jugé là ce n'est donc ce qui pourra
se passer potentiellement c'est les
autres en fait les autres personnes
identifiées ça voudra dire que tous les
commandants militaires russes s'ils sont
identifiés comme étant coupable ne
pourront plus jamais allés à l'étranger
dans un pays qui a ratifié le statut de
rome alors du coup c'est très
intéressant je vous donne la parole là
dessus et reina mais d'abord on écoute
un extrait de de l'intervention du
discours de voldemort zelensky au devant
les nations unies justement sur ce thème
les puissants devons être jugé écoutez
je suis sûr que tous les membres des
nations unies souhaitent connaître la
vérité pourquoi et bien pour punir une
bonne fois pour toutes ceux qui
s'estiment au dessus de tout
et pense pouvoir
commettre de tels crimes en toute
impunité il faut montrer au monde qu'ils
peuvent être punis si les plus puissants
sont punis et bien il
sera possible d'obtenir tous les autres
si
il va au delà voyez ce que je veux dire
il ya le cas poutine d'ailleurs dans
cette
à ce moment là il ne le site absolument
pas il dit c'est presque pour ce conflit
et pour d'autres qu'il faut absolument
faire quelque chose j'interroge
ukrainiens ont tout de suite commencer
le travail qui a été facilitée par le
fait qu'ils sont en coopération déjà sur
le cas de m h 110 est donc cet avion
malazéen airlines qui a été abattu donc
les destructions et le travail s'est
poursuivi donc la cour pénale
internationale qui vaille il ya des
enquêteurs sur le terrain donc il ya
immédiatement des inquiétudes qui sont
venus les ukrainiens ont ouvert grand
les portes cercle l'ukraine n'a pas
signé mais elle reconnaît la juridiction
de 2,7
pour que
je pense qu'il ya la notion morale si
vous voulez qui est extrêmement
importante signer ce n'est pas petit
nice et ça rend les gens
du temps plus direct et en tout cas il
était très important pour le cren
documenté de montrer son ouverture
d'amener des journalistes de toutes les
médias que possible pour pour qu'ils
constatent et ça ce travail va porter
ses fruits et mais un comblement puis il
faut aussi noter que malgré le fait que
l'on puisse pas juger quelqu'un ce
billet qui sera pas potentiellement
coupables ou qui sera pas
potentiellement suspects et très
gravement d'avoir commis des crimes et
on voit qu'effectivement il ya un énorme
effort médiatique qui est poursuivi par
toutes les courbes cas soit pénale
internationale ou même au niveau
national lorsqu'on reconnaît quelqu'un
coupable potentiellement de crimes de
guerre et qu'on attend juste de pouvoir
le déférer devant un tribunal ça met
quand même en coût moral aux actions qui
ont été entreprises et c'est quand même
intrinsèquement positif malgré le manque
de réalisations de se déclarer coupable
dans ce temps le cas le bas des murs
poutine dans le cas du vazzio possibles
sans qu'il soit dans le box
certains procès peuvent avancer par
contumace a été le cas par exemple pour
les pour le tribunal spécial pour le
liban les personnes qui étaient en tout
cas reconnu comme étant potentiellement
coupables n'étaient pas présentes au
procès pour la cour pénale
internationale un peu plus précis parce
qu'on attend en fait que la personne sur
des ferries mais il est tout à fait
possible qui si jamais il ya d'autres
juridictions qu'on puisse juger une
absence yoga effectivement mais ça sera
un peu plus délicat pour la demo footing
qui n'ont en tout cas n'est peut-être
pas la personne a pu visés par ces
poursuites elle sera potentiellement ses
subalternes alors justement 2000 train
quand est ce que est ce que c'est cette
menace de procès pour on va pas pour
l'instant parler de crimes de guerre et
on va employer d'autres termes est-ce
que ça peut freiner certains gradés
certains militaires russes écoutez je
vais faire une comparaison qui va
peut-être vous choquer mais comme le
président poutine parle de dé nazifié
moi je vais parler de l'époque nazie
scène déjà absolument pas freiné au
contraire il partait dans un telle fuite
vers l'avant une fois que ces exactions
ont commencé ils savent que toute façon
et d'une certaine façon ils seront pris
un jour ou l'autre donc ils partent dans
cette espèce de folie meurtrière vous
savez les les exactions qu'on a connue
chez nous un oradour-sur-glane unité ss
dans lequel il y avait beaucoup de gens
des pays de l'est d'ailleurs inquiétée
dans il comprit aussi des alsaciens qui
avaient été enrôlés à ce moment là mais
en fait ça a été une fuite vers l'avant
et on s'aperçoit que beaucoup des
exactions commises en france ils ont été
pendant l'été 44 après le débarquement
en normandie voir après le débarquement
en provence 1 donc je pense que si vous
voulez les gens qui sont dans cette
logique là sont totalement hors contrôle
alors c'est pour ça que je pose la
question de savoir si c'est des unités
particulière parce que quand je parle
des nazis s'étaient souvent des unités
ss donc très politisés ou est-ce que
c'est l'ensemble de l'armée russe qui
répondent comme ça ça je ne sais pas il
a déjà la procureure le crès n'indique
pour l'instant on se concentre sur
buttes chamkhi à d'autres villes
brillante et elle a employé l'expression
de ce que vous découvrez ce qui s'est
passé là-bas ça vous habillera l'âme
c'est à dire que les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui se prépare à la découverte
d'autres choses aussi bien à la région
de rack que dans la région de kent et au
ensuite viendra
la question étant de là on peut savoir
et enquêter sur ce qui s'est passé à
bout de chat ou dans les autres vides
ont parlé parce que l'armée ukrainienne
en a on a repris le contrôle si c'est
l'armée russe qui prend le contrôle de
marioupol on saura peut-être jamais
vraiment ce qui s'y est passé ou en tout
cas ça prendra beaucoup plus de temps
tout à fait ce qui serait plus difficile
c'est de recouper parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a ce qu'on a constaté on a les
témoignages on allait les fastes les
victimes les ceux qui ont été témoin
donc on recoupe quand même les
témoignages sur plusieurs plans
peut-être sur les villes qui ne seront
pas sous le contrôle l'ukrainien pendant
longtemps on n'effacera les traces et on
aura peut-être sûr que quelques quelques
témoignages et parce qu'ils ne pourront
pas être écoutés on ne voit pas
suffisamment pour sa licence pour les
médias occidentaux enfin point je sais
c'est qu'en fait on est on est au milieu
de la propagande russe et de la
communication et craignent haine et il
faudrait que les journalistes aussi
français puissent aller filmer parce que
les images qu'on a vu et et on n'avait
pas les femmes les enfants raconte donc
voilà on n'est pas du tout ça en cause
mais si vous voulez on n'a pas du tout
accès à un voilà toute la mine
d'informations que vous avez en images
en photo et donc c'est difficile de
pouvoir conclure de façon radicale et
définitive sans avoir le matériel vous
avez commencé passé l'armée russe se
retire elle d'abord c'était les
démineurs ukrainiens qui ont passé parce
que le terrain était complètement miné
ensuite le lendemain pratiquement on a
on a fait venir le journaliste donc ça a
été très vite vous parliez de la
propagande russe le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov qui
continue de nier la responsabilité
de ses soldats il accuse l'ukraine d'une
mise en scène et c'est exactement ce que
l'ambassadeur de la russie auprès de
l'onu a répété hier soir écouter
depuis le début il est clair qu'il ne
s'agit de rien d'autre qu'une
provocation orchestrés visant à
discréditer et déshumanisée l'armée
russe et à exercer une pression
politique sur la russie aux prochains
jeux olympiques m qu'est ce qui peut se
passer côté russe face à une institution
je sais qu'il ya alors c'est intéressant
parce qu'il ya des des magistrats
ukrainien évidemment qui enquêtent il ya
la cour pénale internationale il ya des
magistrats français ya le parquet
antiterroriste français qui s'est saisie
d'au moins 3 cas parce que des
ressortissants français sont sont morts
en ukraine que peut faire la russie
c'est à dire celle va faire on imagine
qu'elle va faire obstruction que
quelqu'un comment ça se passe en fait
que des instructions comme celle là
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
normalement théoriquement c'est l'état
qui est censé juger sur son propre
territoire des violations qui ont été
commises à l'homme par exemple en france
si nos militaires à l'étranger viole le
droit de la guerre ce sera primordial
ment à la france de les juger sur son
territoire que ce soit par le biais de
sanctions ni sera-t-il sanctions pénales
là on se rend bien compte que en russie
potentiellement ce ne sera pas le cas
avant même sa ne sera vraiment pas le
cas et donc on espère en tout cas que ce
que ce soit des états qui obtient de ce
qu'on appelle la compétence universelle
c'est-à-dire une compétence qui permet
de juger de crimes ni commis sur leur
territoire et non plus par des personnes
qui sont leurs nationaux de juger de ces
crimes là par exemple on sait que la
suisse a une conception assez large de
cette compétence est donc on se dit que
si jamais des militaires russes
identifié à un moment où voyagent dans
un de ces pays qui auraient de cette
compétence spécifique ou rire et reconnu
la compétence de la cour pénale
internationale qui les auraient
identifié à ce moment là on pourra en
fait les déférer auprès d'une cour
qu'elles soient nationales ou
internationales mais ça reste
effectivement des cas de figure assez
spécifique mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est voilà c'est le volet
reconnaissance des crimes avant même
tout en 2 j -gc risation qui est quand
même assez important notamment dans des
villes où au bout de chaque homme mario
paul par exemple alors s'il ya je crois
une ima une déclaration que l'on doit
retenir de cette journée elle est issue
du discours de volodymyr zelensky devant
les nations unies on en a eu un extrait
tout à l'heure mais l'extrait plus
important le voilà ils placent vraiment
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu devant
ses contradictions
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin que le
conseil de sécurité prenne une décision
en faveur de la paix vous pouvez soit
exclure la russie en tant qu'agresseur
en tant que faiseur de guerre afin que
la russie ne puisse pas bloquer des
décisions qui concernent sa propre
guerre et son agression et ensuite on
pourra commencer à faire la paix gerald
train quand je rappelle que vous
dirigiez là la mission militaire
française auprès de l'onu s'il ya une
institution vous connaissez bien c'est
celle là où quand comme moi j'ai entendu
ce qui vole aussi mis en scène des skis
je me suis dis bah oui c'est une
évidence et en même temps ça n'arrivera
jamais ça n'arrivera pas il faut
refonder complètement l'onu puisque la
russie est membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité
donc ça ne peut pas changer comme ça
demande une auto dissolution justement
de ce conseil décide
si vous voulez on dans ce cas là on va
qu'est ce qu'on va recréer à la place ça
fait 20 ans qu'on en parle donc depuis
20 ans on n'y arrive pas
il y avait des projets sur élargir le
conseil retirer le droit de vote et
cetera et cetera tout ceci n'a pas
fonctionné en revanche si vous voulez ce
qu'il faut voir quand même c'est qu'il
ya quand même réunion du conseil de
sécurité et que l'ukraine peut
s'exprimer tous les pays peuvent
s'exprimer on peut écouter l'ambassadeur
russe qui s'expriment qui comme vous le
disiez reprend les propos de monsieur
lavrov donc tout le monde est au courant
des mensonges qui sont mis sur la table
alors que toutes les preuves arrive de
l'autre côté c'est déjà quelque chose je
veux dire l'onu sur des sujets comme ça
ne peut pas prendre de discussion de
décisions pardon en revanche est un
espace dans lequel on peut exprimer les
choses et là on parle du conseil de
sécurité mais regardons bien l'assemblée
générale l'assemblée générale des
nations unies a pris une décision la
semaine dernière
ses 93 193 mans
140 ont pris la décision contre la
guerre en ukraine donc ça veut dire
cinquante trois n'ont pas pris et on
avait six ou sept qui étaient contre les
autres se sont abstenus
mais c'est quoi ça c'est la moitié du
monde la moitié de la population
mondiale représentait aux nations unies
ne s'est pas opposé à la guerre en
ukraine et sadique oui parce que je suis
la motive mandant population parce que
son population
mais ça dit quelque chose de la fracture
du monde qu'on a aujourd'hui ou si vous
voulez moi je l'aimé je l' ai vécu il ya
vingt ans à l'onu où nos valeurs la
façon dont la démocratie avancée et
c'est n'est pas accepté par beaucoup de
pays mais sa pointe aussi une train
quand la chimère d'un d'une gouvernance
mondiale en baby sur non mais bien sûr
non mais tout à fait puisque je veux
souligner c'est qu'il ne faut pas
s'imaginer que parce que nous pensons
comme ça tout le monde pense comme ça
oui ça c'est à voir
la dmr poutine joue là dessus on en
disant tout ça c'est de la faute des
américains des occidentaux de leur
valeur pourri et cetera faut l'avoir en
tête parce que j'interviens pas mal sur
des plateaux étrangers au moyen-orient
afrique etc et vous seriez surpris des
messages qu'on m'envoie par la tonalité
vous dire parlez moi de la libération du
donbass
bon c'est ça les messages qu'on entend
il faut le garder un lien il ailleurs on
va parler des sanctions européennes dans
un instant mais je voudrais vous
entendre une amie de mitry chine sur ce
que les russes voient pas ce que vous
êtes aussi voilà vous pouvez regarder
les télévisions russes et et on a aussi
du mal à imaginer parce qu'on parlait
des soldats russes ont parlé qui
communiquent avec leurs familles ce
lavage de cerveau subie par les russes
depuis des années dépit des années et
particulièrement dans le cadre de ce qui
se passe c'est à dire qu'on a réactivé
la grande guerre patriotique les nazis
et c est en gros les russes voient les
mêmes images mais commenter de manière
totalement inverse c'est à dire qu'on
dit que ce sont les ukrainiens qui
bombardent les ukrainiens qui affame et
cetera et cetera donc il ya intel
montait de rage aussi de l'autre côté de
on serait surpris de ceux de se dire
mais comment les gens peuvent avaler
tout cela mais vous ne vous cassez les
médias indépendants ou fait partir le
journaliste vous vous en tuer un certain
nombre et c est donc le champ qui reste
c'est juste la propagande d'état dans un
seul sens qu'ils donnent toute la
machine est aujourd'hui sur ce conflit
ils ont une inversion de la vérité non
j'en avais la vérité alternative avec
donald trump a vu la lumière poutine on
à la vérité a versé fin il faut regarder
ce qui se passe sur les télés russes et
montre les images en option les
ukrainiens et ont tué
avec les mêmes images
qu'un gros tampon fake qui vraiment
aussi rappelle tous les univers des
feuilles news etc face et la propagande
elle est totale et un mot là-dessus oui
j'ai juste un mot on se demande s'il
croit leurs mensonges c'est je me suis
en disait ça car à l'époque communiste
j'ai pas la chance de parler russe comme
vous donc je me fais traduire tous les
réseaux et quand je reçois ça on
interprète qu'ils m'envoient tout ça m'a
dit mais on est revenu à l'époque de
staline c'est effarant effarant ce qui
se passe de l'autre côté elle est le
chapitre consacré dans ce débat à la
réaction de l'union européenne un
nouveau train de sanctions était déjà en
préparation avant le massacre découvert
à bout de chats et pour le ministre
français des affaires étrangères la
question du gaz et surtout du pétrole
est posé on écoute jean yves le drian en
raison de l'aggravation de la situation
et de l'effroi que
donnent ces images que nous avons pu
constater nous devons engager
assakane paquet de sanctions avec
l'horizon du conseil des affaires
étrangères du 11 et nous travaillons
ensemble et moi même la france et
l'allemagne à la définition de ce que
pourrait être ce nouveau paquet qui
devra intégrer
le pétrole et le charbon
messieurs les dispos les modalités de la
mise en oeuvre qui font l'objet
aujourd'hui de discussion je crois utile
pour parler de ces sanctions j'accueille
avec nous en duplex olivier d'orgon
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes avocat
spécialisé sans sion sanctions
économiques membres du cabinet ashurst
alors c'est intéressant d'écouter jean
luc de rire le drian il parle de pétrole
et de charbon il ne parle pas de de gaz
est ce qu'un embargo sur le pétrole
russe où vous l'aviez déjà évoqué sur ce
plateau mais c'est important de le
le redire et le détail et est-ce qu'il
est plus facile à mettre en place cet
embargo sur le pétrole russe
alors l'embargo sur le pétrole russe en
tant qu'elle est plus facile à se mettre
à mettre en place pour des raisons de
logistique
on est toujours plus simple de
transporter le pétrole que de
transporter du gaz pour des raisons de
réseaux pour des raisons de liquéfaction
et de regazéification du gaz une fois
qu'il a été il est arrivé au port de
destination donc c'est en termes
d'infrastructures c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de transformer des 2 remplace
celle des infrastructures d'acheminement
de gaz que de remplacer des
infrastructures d'acheminement de
pétrole qui se transporte de manière
assez simple un peu par bateau après
pour revenir à propos de jean-yves le
drian on voit aujourd'hui s'ouvrir un
nouveau front dans les fonctions donc on
voit que le secteur de l'énergie qui
était un facteur qui pendant ce temps qu
un secteur interdit ou pas en tout cas
les européennes s'interdisait et
insectes et un secteur que les réseaux
européens ont envie de commencer à
occuper parce qu'ils ont conscience du
fait que c'est une manne financière très
importante pour la russie mais par
contre on voit encore une fois une forme
de désunion entre la position française
qui est extrait par emmanuel macron ce
week-end et qui a été reprise par lan et
de l'audio qui a été suivie d'une forme
de réaction relativement positive de la
part de l'allemagne dans un premier
temps mais sur lequel a priori en tout
cas là où je vous parle ce soir on a
vraiment plus là un embargo sur le
charbon et pas sur le pétrole et sur le
charbon une des raisons pour laquelle on
s'en bat tsonga standard gossé qui la
crainte de certains pays qui sont par
ailleurs très dépendants du gaz russe
sait que si on imposait un embargo sur
le pétrole russe qui représente 6 des
recettes financer un beaucoup plus
importante que le gaz pour la russie on
prendrait le risque de voir la russie à
prendre des contre mesures qui
pourraient par exemple prendre la forme
d'une restriction ou d'un arrêt des
exportations de gaz vers l'union
européenne donc on est vraiment dans ce
point d'équilibré on a des signaux forts
ce soir de la part de bruxelles sur un
accord sur le charbon qui représente une
petite manne financière pour la pour la
pour la russie quand même on parle de
environ 4 à 5 milliards d'euros d'export
et la russie et l'europe est en marche
et qui raconte en tiers des exportations
de charbon pour la russie donc c'est
quand même assez handicapant mais on est
très loin ils feraient des montants du
gaz et surtout du pétrole qui se chiffre
plutôt aux alentours au niveau européen
200 millions à 100 millions d'euros oui
donc c'est ça c'est 4 millions pour le
charbon c'est 100 millions pour le
pétrole et le gaz ces intermédiaires
c'est ça
exactement oui d'accord est ce qu'il ya
des deux nouvelles banques russes qui
pourraient être visées par
ce nouveau train de sanctions celles qui
sont justement en lien avec l'énergie
alors justement là aussi on voit qu'il
ya un alignement qui est en train de se
dessiner comme vous l'avez peut-être
suivi la deuxième banque commerciale
russe vtb avait fait l'objet de
sanctions au niveau américain et au
niveau britannique depuis maintenant
quelques semaines le l'union européenne
n'avait pas souhaité aller dans ce sens
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
même si ce n'est pas la banque de
l'énergie comme peut l'être gazprombank
c'est quand même la deuxième banque
commerciale du pays donc la crainte
était que dans l'hypothèse des ventes
réelles des bords de flux financiers un
petit seraient relatifs à l'export de
pétrole ou de gaz russe vtb puisse
éventuellement jouer donc là on apprend
également au titre des communications
officielles pour l'instant de l'union
européenne que vtb fera partie de cette
nouvelle vague de sanctions mais on ne
touche pour l'instant pas agace prône
manga tremblant qui de toute manière
depuis la semaine dernière depuis la
décision et les contrats majeurs qui
avaient adopté par valli mère fotina un
rôle chez parce que comme on a
longuement commenté il est dorénavant
exigé de la part oublie les exportateurs
et les importateurs européens qu'ils
ouvrent des comptes auprès de
gazprombank pour pouvoir honorer leurs
dettes auprès des créanciers russes en
roubles et donc si on venait visées de
fête gaie cependant conviendrait
interdire l'import de gaz russe donc
servir est probable c'est pour cette
raison que notamment les pays comme
l'allemagne où certains et l'italie et
d'autres pays d'europe de l'est sont
opposées à des sanctions contre
gazprombank odier d'orange reste avec
vous
je voudrais vous entendre sur la les
conséquences de la réélection du
pro-russe viktor orban hongrie est ce
que ça complique forcément les futures
décisions de sanctions européennes et ce
qu'il faut forcément une unanimité pour
décider de ces sanctions ou pas
paradoxalement alors pour répondre à
votre question enfin l'indien parce que
votre question oui les sanctions
économiques européennes sont prises à
l'unanimité elles sont prises par
décision du conseil de l'europe et
ensuite elles sont mises en oeuvre et
mise en musique si vous le souhaitez par
la commission européenne qui adopte un
règlement qui est d'application directe
dans l'espace européen le viktor orban
est intéressant c'est qu'il y avait une
position avec assez complexe parce
qu'ils étaient en train de mener
compagne depuis maintenant quelques
semaines et donc il était assez
compliqué pour lui d'avoir un discours
qu'ils soient où qu'ils deviennent
orthez les intérêts économiques hors de
l'ombre il peut pour pour le coup la
hongrie est très dépendant très
consommatrice de matières énergétiques
ou de matières fossiles russe et donc
ils auront peut-être est un peu plus là
pour lui dans le cadre de sa campagne de
s'afficher sur en faveur d'un embargo
sur ces sujets aujourd'hui maintenant
qu'il est utile à priori pour ta ble
ment est lui
réélu par dong wei ça peut être
intéressant de se demander si ça ne va
pas au contraire peut-être le pousser
parce qu'il est par ailleurs mis au ban
des pays européens par certains de ses
alliés de justement essayer de négocier
une forme d'adhésion sur ce type dans
d'embargo ne pas voir matière pétrolière
et gazière et éventuellement en échange
d'une forme de mansuétude de la part des
états européens je pense que le nerf de
la guerre il faut pas se tromper un
honneur n'a guère aujourd'hui entame de
d'avancé sur secteur d'énergie c'est
l'italie l'accidentel italiens et
allemands et c'est pour ça qu'on scrute
avec beaucoup d'intérêt beaucoup
d'attention les positions qui sont
prises par l'allemagne d'ailleurs une
forme de cacophonie en allemagne ces 24
dernières heures on a eu une avancée sur
l'ouverture dans chambre énergie et
éventuellement au pétrole ce qui a
permis à emmanuel macro agents de drion
de tenir des propos vous avez diffusé à
l'instant on n'est pas
en ce cas le ministère de l'économie non
seulement rappelé que ce n'était pas en
tout cas le swing d'allemagne donc je
pense que tant que l'allemagne du temps
qu'ils ne bougeront pas sur ces sujets
le pétrole et le gaz qui sont vous
l'aurez compris h est intrinsèquement
lié notamment en matière
d'interdépendance et de recettes
représentent de pétrole pour la russie
ne seront pas au menu des sanctions
économiques que futur alors qu'ils sont
pas des pros russe des tice et on va
s'intéresser un peu à notre campagne
présidentielle les positions pro poutine
de marine le pen de jean luc mélenchon
ou même d'eric zemmour d'ailleurs vous
vous avez le sentiment que ça n'aura pas
vraiment coûté des points dans cette
campagne on aurait pu croire que les
mois populaire suscité par la guerre en
ukraine les ralentissent dans cette dans
le dernier mois là qu'on a vécu de
campagne et pour eric zemmour certes il
a décru mais c'est surtout à cause de
ses positions en contre les l'accueil
des réfugiés ukrainien plus que pour
poutine je vous rappelle il disait qu'il
rêvait d'un poutine français en 2018 on
l'a ressorti un bien sûr qu on ressort
les archives mais il n'y a pas de
conséquences directes marine le pen
continue à gagner des points alors
qu'elle avait rencontré vladimir poutine
en 2017 qu'elle a contracté un prêt
russe pour sa campagne là actuellement
et puis jean luc mélenchon lui aussi en
grange encore des soutiens alors que
comme marine le pen il prend soin de
condamner la russie ça c'est fait pour
les 3 mai de jamais le faire nommément
écouté ce matin par exemple il était sur
sud radio écoutez ce qu'il dit à propos
des responsables de cette bien c'est
vraiment du crime de guerre c'est
intolérable et ça ne doit pas être
toléré j'espère qu'il y aura le moment
venu des sanctions ça va pas être simple
parce que les gens doivent savoir que
l'onu ne peut juger que des états le
seul tribunal international qui peut
juger des personnes
ni la russie ni les états unis ni la
chine n'ont signé la convention qui
l'institut ça va donc pas être facile
d'y renvoyer les responsables on a déjà
expliqué sam et où il est responsable il
ne dit jamais poutine vraiment je vous
mets au défi de revoir toutes les de
réécouter toutes leurs leurs interviews
poutine ce mot est vraiment très
rarement prononcée alors je pose ici une
hypothèse s'il n'y a aucune conséquence
aucun impact sur leur progression dans
la campagne peut-être que leurs
électorats respectifs sont alignés sur
la position ces trois candidats marine
le pen eric zemmour jean luc mélenchon
ils ont un autre point commun oui ils
remettent sans cesse l'otan en cause et
pointe la responsabilité de l'otan dans
le déclenchement de cette guerre et les
trois veulent au moins à minima sortir
de son commandement intégré ce qui fait
que on vote dans quelques jours et il y
a dans cette élection une ligne de
fracture très très claire entre un camp
qui est plutôt progressiste pro-européen
et puis l'autre camp donc de ces trois
candidats les extrêmes souverainiste
merci de cette analyse laetitia irina
dmitri shikin vrai de savoir ce que ça
évoque chez vous deux voire trois 3
candidats et qui ont affiché à des
degrés divers mais quand même une
proximité voire une admiration pour
vladimir poutine à ce haut niveau dans
l'est dans les sondages à cinq jours de
la présidentielle française n'est pas du
tout étonné on savait que les extrêmes
avait beaucoup d'admiration pour petit
pour des raisons différentes je pense
que l'extrême gauche garde encore cette
admiration pour moscou donc c'est malgré
tout donc la révolution a passé par là
et puis pour l'extrême droite est à
cette opération de la main forte de
décisions qui sont prises par un parent
seul homme donc et ça n'a rien
d'étonnant maintenant est ce que est ce
que leur électorat et sur leurs
positions ou tout simplement parce que
ce n'est pas du tout une question qui
entrent en ligne de compte dans la
réflexion du de compliqué parce que
quand on sonde les électeurs et se
disent intéressé concernés par déjà la
question internationale est d'autant
plus la gare en ukraine donc s'ils sont
concernés et s'il décide quand même de
ne les envoient à priori dans les
intentions de vote ça veut dire qu'ils
sont alignés si marine le pen a fait
accent sur le social c'est peut-être ça
aussi qui est sûr c'est une façon de
gommer de plus ces questions-là auprès
de son
jeune kirk à marine le pen elle affirme
que le président russe peu re devenir un
allié mais si on se positionne sur votre
expertise c'est à dire la question des
des procédures on va dire juridique on
peut imaginer quand même un flot des
murs poutine qui sera pour longtemps au
ban des nations
mais non en fait la grande question
effectivement en droit international en
général et dans les nations unies ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est la
question de l'opprobre en fête
internationale plus l'idée se dire que
malgré le fait qu'ils puissent ne pas y
avoir de sanction juridique c'est-à-dire
auprès de la cour internationale de
justice qui jugeait entre les états et
cour pénale qui fait pour les individus
en fait il ya toujours un opprobre et
effectivement une mise au ban de la
personne qui s'est rendu coupable on l'a
vu en syrie avec bachar el-assad on l'a
vu pour d'autres pour d'autres états qui
sont rendus par exemple via de marne
notamment et donc j'étais cette espèce
en tout cas de condamnation morale de la
part de la communauté internationale qui
a un impact direct sur la vie de l'état
on voit avec les sanctions économiques
on verra ensuite avec potentiellement
des sanctions judiciaires et donc
effectivement tout cas poutine n'est pas
prêt pour l'instant alors à de rares
pays qui continuent à le soutenir à
revenir en tout cas sur le devant de la
scène en tant que grand saut vers qu'il
pense être un tout derniers mois mais
très vite alors il juste un mot le le
peuple russe n'est pas notre ennemi ça
on peut le dire oui il est le président
poutine malheureusement à démontrer ce
qu'il était capable de faire merci
beaucoup encore une fois merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce
débats et